achtung achtung ich lass mich das nicht
vorkommt da viele dass viele ich muss
hier raus komme bary namen haven letzte
folge aber nichts geschafft wir haben
hier so ein bisschen so ein bisschen
sachen ausgebaut
ich würde sagen dass du jetzt eventuell
in der folge vielleicht diese bedachung
da oben fertig machst weil ich habe hier
so viel stein jetzt gerade geholt kann
ich damit gerne machen ja weil dann kann
ich ein bisschen angeln weil das ist
nämlich die einzige sache um die wir uns
kümmern können weil ich habs jetzt schon
sehr auf gezeigt wir haben nebenan schon
eine kiste in einem wasser dingsbums und
da kommen wir in einem erfolg dran und
du machst hier
ich mache gerade hier das becken wenig
größer genau du da auch mal rein passt
oder nicht immer in öl erst wenn du mal
einspringen
woher kommt eigentlich die ganzen stadt
spielzeiten hier drin hast du sie ihr
angebot hier habe ich auch gegen 7 uhr
kripo soll ich hab dir da ein bisschen
steine hingeschmissen
wow da kannst du damals anders solange
ich gehe angeln du musst diese
bedachungen da oben weiter bauen
ok also ist aber erstmal bin ich das
becken noch vernünftig machen
das ist ein wunderschöner becken war das
tier das ist jede größere strömung als
bei der toilette also da musste erst mal
aushelfen und ausbessern jetzt aber ich
habe ja nun einmal gerne wie immer hier
eben die sachen bitte da kriege ich aber
eher die krise da schmeiße ich ja 5
million mal sachen ja die schaufel will
ich auch nicht ob meine alten schaufel
ist ein blöder aber jetzt machen und du
hast ja wasser einfüllen
man kriegt die strömung nicht weg wenn
natürlich soll ich machen
guck doch ich selbst überall an rand was
ja gib mir mal alter und dann kommt du
hast ja gesagt durch so viel die steine
mir gegeben hast du aber auch nur 1 tag
dann machte mir das dach fertig ja genau
immer wieder mal in folge so richtig
interessante sachen machen dachbau er
ist doch auch mal interessante sache sei
froh das ist dach bauer in deutschland
gibt ja ja danke dass es euch gibt
dachbau ist so wundervoll von euch hat
mekka in becher der witz ist schon
schwerer arbeit und da muss man finde
ich sagen respekt die die täglich auf
das dach von neuenstein und auch respekt
zusagen für leute die klos putzen das
ist so irre ich würde ihn dann seine
chlor eingreifen würden sehr sehr eklig
[Musik]
dieses dach mit sehr schön aber wir
brauchen so was von vielen steine dafür
noch aber du hast doch trotz weise hast
du eben vorher noch gesagt ja bestimmt
40 stück habe ich noch nie 30 oder 31
die wir bisher mit einem es geht voran
aber es gibt jetzt gibt vorn
[Musik]
ja weiß nicht als wir machen das ganze
hier oben damit diese absperrung dass da
unten sollten nicht regen hinkommt und
beispielsweise das also für mspe
und das da zum beispiel auch vor allem
der gas und keiner mops kaputt schießt
ja ich denke das sollte eigentlich schon
laufen ja dann gibt man jetzt mal eine
angel
da kann ich doch nebenbei schon mal
angeln das geht doch in so ein becken
nicht gibt jetzt die angel ist ja okay
nicht selbst die kuh die strecke ist
[Musik]
jetzt wie ich mach das jetzt auch wie du
jeder muss doch jetzt mal langsam was
kommt
das kann doch nicht sein dass einfach
kein fisch kommt oder kommen die
wirklich nur unsere natur teilchen und
ich wenn mir das selbst baut also ich
bin mir sicher dass man das auch wenn
sie hier machen kann
aber ich weiß nicht ob das ein backwaren
und das jetzt mal in dem snapshot war in
dem snap habe ich schreibe euch gespielt
aber kann ja sein dass das irgendwie
jetzt nicht mehr geht
aber eigentlich dürfte es noch gehen
da kommen aber nichts du hast ja auch
alles kaputt gemacht und daraus er
bleibt einfach drin
jetzt kann ich nicht mal mehr anderen
hier hatte da das becken ein bisschen
höher wiedergeborene mich das päckli
wird ich gehe wieder zu meiner alten
stelle man den korken
das ist sich herzlich was ist mein herz
haben wir ein ziemlich einfach alles
fertig und den posten ab nee du musst
das ja noch mal hier ab ohne dass
darunter dann muss ich nicht dass ich da
tiefer wird das hängt damit gar nichts
zusammen
einbeck da drüben ist auch nicht tief
habe ja auch nicht angehen können ich
glaube unsere becken geht das nicht doch
das geht so kommt mir davon werde jetzt
weiter wie geht's dir so ganz gut das
geht nicht wenn die laster mal ein
bisschen verbauen wieder mach was du
meinst du hast es komplett zugebaut
wieder so wie andere sie da oben er da
muss man die leute hier gehen die man
hier auf die höhe und dann und dann
angel mal ein frohes angel
ich lese ein wenig in minecraft wichtig
dass jetzt der angel blog du sagst mir
etwas angst ich hab gerade überlegt
warum brauchen wir endlich den server
tisch wir brauchen bücher ja darüber
sehen bekommen doch jetzt zur scheiße
arschloch fisch dazu vielleicht noch
höher als diese messer plattform dar um
das vielleicht noch so eine plattform wo
man ran kann ich will gar nicht hoch wie
noch höher als in der plattform kann
doch sein oder ich höre es klappt nicht
mit einem v8 kommt der hat mich es muss
klappen eigentlich aber runde
[Musik]
das kann doch nicht sein
lol lol lol nicht so lange was zu angeln
dass das irgendwie irgendwie geht das
nicht wir müssen das irgendwie super
dass der gruppe wieder so toll
informiert dass hier
es hat geklappt bei mir hundertwasser
geträumt vielleicht haben
ich auf video mit dem pixel wulfen ja
bei sky blog das ist ja auch was anderes
sind die gleichen nein da ist es auch
gleich eigentlich heiße was wir denn
jetzt sonst auch machen an den erfolgen
ich bin mir auch nicht zwischen ja ich
brauche ein wenig überfragt hätten wir
auch eine kuh das wird ja schon hatte
ist oder eine kuh also werden dass eine
kuh dann kamen wir doch irgendwie war da
was
er hatte noch der ein erfolg für pan ich
habe das gefühl wir töten zu wir haben
noch viel weniger
ich töte dich da keine mehr ich würde
eigentlich habe die stärken der einfach
von selbst so aber gar nicht kümmern
ich bin ja so gefragt was wir machen
könnten schreibt er bitte unter diese
folge wahrscheinlich bevor er diese
folge online habt haben wir schon jetzt
wieder aufgenommen naja warum man kann
ja schon meiner folge wahrscheinlich
sehen dass wir ein problem da haben dann
kommt bestimmt schon reichlich
vorschläge ich bin ja gerade wieder beim
and portal vielleicht kann mir hier beim
and portal wo die boarder ja stimmen
wollen
das sieht sehr gut aus was dann die
porta ist anscheinend hier voll weit weg
gegangen
du weißt doch noch unten der raum mit
den silber fischen oder er ist dadurch
ja klar
dann scheint kann man da jetzt lang
genug es gibt doch ein erfolg entdecke
das ende oder so dann muss man auch nur
dieses ende auge da rein machen muss man
das wirklich nur rein machen
ja man werde ein auge
wenn eine auge wir haben nur eine perle
ja ich auch so warte mal sieht aber sehr
gut aus hier darf ich noch nicht getötet
werden kann man lieber runter eigentlich
weil ich gleich tot bin ja was ich muss
gut überlegen was ich neues mitnehmen
von einer perle mit navy machen sich
dann eine auge das weiß ich ja alle
bedroht ja gut stimmt du mal okay ich
hab s geschafft und ich lebe noch näher
war hier unten können wir nicht wirklich
weitermachen
zum glück habe ich noch mal hier unten
nachgeguckt gras ende auge dafür
brauchen wir lohnen staub und ich gebe
doch wir haben einen wehrlosen guten ich
habe zwei lohnstopp sicher dass wir
wirklich bei dem portal ende augen
reinmachen müssen sie also nicht aber
wir können ja so dass ja klar wir müssen
auf jeden fall ende augen reinpacken
ich schaue mir auch mal den erfolg dafür
anwarb mal also der erfolg besagt dass
ende fragezeichen finde das anders heißt
zu müssen wenn wahrscheinlich nur ein
ende august auch das symbol vom ende
auge hat nenner auge reimer einmal rein
stecken so dann dann kommt danach noch
ein erfolg mit das ende das bedeutet
wahrscheinlich dann müssen wir da rein
springen
das sieht ja das hört sich alles schon
mal sehr vielversprechend an finde ich
ich habe jetzt mal eine dings gemacht
und bringe am besten aber die diamanten
spitzhacke dass sie mal warum ich habe
jetzt ein
was denn eine falsche ich dachte wohl es
erfolge machen
die briefe wurden anja dass ich hier
nicht abbauen musste eine leiter für
abbauen und dann ja wir haben ja noch
eine falsche daran okay gut dann mach
ich packe ich einfach mal wieder hier
rein weil es so wir können in der folge
auch mal was schaffen würden du kommen
würde ist ja ich bin ja unterwegs jetzt
auch ich komme ich etwas mitbringen
außerdem augen hast du deine augen ich
habe zwei ende augen nicht an der penne
sondern ende augen bin unterwegs nach
unten wieder ins heim so ich sehe schon
deinen namen müssen wir uns immer
zwischen appell aufpassen die spanner
von denen abbauen weil die bringen uns
um
ich weiß auch nicht wie wir am besten
davor gehen und gegen die einer sollte
die ablenken und der andere sollte
reineren lava habe ich schon entfernt
soll ich hab mal eine orgel darin
platzieren er geht ja noch nicht
erfolgen
[Musik]
guck mal wir kommen doch noch nicht ganz
da hin
die wand so vielversprechend achtung
achtung
ich lass mich das nicht kommt da viele
dass vieles kaputt ich muss weg ich muss
hier raus ich habe noch zwei herzen ich
bin raus ich verziehe mich mal was essen
da kommen ja welche
der klettert daher etwas setzen
ich hab noch essen ich brauche nicht
geschafft das war die wahl wir mal
unsichtbar weil ich jeden moment moment
hilft mir einfach töte alle ich gemacht
wo kommen die alle her war das
spitzenteam mit scheiße hier steigen
jetzt schnell gestellt wird ist es
schwer die ich auch jetzt warte ich
generieren und dann gehe ich da auch
bringen schwert mit
ich habe keins wirken barry und das an
jahren habe ich alle verbrachten wir
später machen aber mache ich nein macht
heidi erschwert
ich bin vorher zeugt mit vielleicht kann
ich die paar hütchen vielleicht kann ich
dir verbrennen aber mal hast du dir da
dir dass die türen zugemacht welche tür
ja das tag 1 x nachkommt oder so war ich
nicht also ich bin jetzt wir bei dir
die kommen auch immer nach glaube ich
glaube weil er eine tür offen ist okay
okay da kommen die tür ist zu
aber ich höre ich immer noch hier unten
sind die die kommen wir alle noch
durchkommen ich habe noch ein paar
sachen von mir warte warte mal ich bin
gerade ihren kampf mit dem quasi wieder
mit hochleben
wer besser ist und das machst ja ich
nehme einfach mal erst mal alles mit
hoch
jetzt fehlt auch noch eine leiter ich
komme ja wir mit hoch weil man alles
kaputt wieder hier manchmal man krass
trasse folge wir dürfen hier schon
wieder was
über 666 hexe am heck sala kommt schnell
hoch nein ich sie bremst aber sie
verbrennt ja gar nichts der hexe können
wir galten ja voran
du bist lustig einfach angreifen
so trenne okay was hat dir gegeben nix
doch ein stapler englisch aber es gibt
ein stab ich habe keinen stab alter
vielleicht war das deine scheiss
entscheidung die ganze räume wieder
aufzubauen
aber wir haben alles ausgeleuchtet ja
gut was wieder zu nord geführt so wie
ich was sache ist ja alles in die luft
gesprengt worden
sehr cool also bei unseren folgen bei
uns sehr in folge hat man sowas von buzz
zu achten
das ist ja nicht mehr normal hat man
sowas ich hatte mich ich gehe nach oben
ich komme mal gar nicht mehr darauf klar
viel zu viel was passiert hier ja aber
wir brauchen eure hilfe wir leute ja
wirklich eure hilfe was jetzt irgendwie
ist hätte der folge vielleicht müssen
wir jetzt die ewigkeiten warten bis eine
coole wie ich habe mal kommt aber es
kommt ja keine gut vielleicht ich hoffe
immer noch drei kühe und er wird wir nur
eine wussten die anderen kühen ich frage
mich das seit wir hier sind wird
deutschland den zweiten weltkrieg
verloren hat wir würden sagen ich würde
genau
ich mache ein bisschen dubstep hier ich
möchte das schon
ich kann zwar wieder die karotten so ein
bisschen an und dann sind wir in der
nächsten folge wieder beim start
hoffentlich mit euren tipps ich habe
jetzt ja die zwei ende augen gemacht
ob sie uns was bringen ist eine andere
sache
34 feilhaber oder sonst ein ball ich hab
noch ein eisen brustpanzer von dir den
spaß bei ihnen hierhin ist das fleisch
haben wir auch noch so kann man auch
fressen hier
da liegt auch noch was drin hab ich von
ihm schon gesehen und doch irgendwie hab
ich grad schon für die dings ausgegeben
für die für die konnten ja ja ja gut
dann würde ich aber trotzdem sagen dass
ich muss mir noch neues schwert machen
ich auch werden einfach mal die
komplette alle schwerter alle waffen für
uns verdichtet
[Musik]
naja will schreibt uns auf jeden fall
schon mal dinge die wir machen können
das haben wir schon letzte folge und
auch vorletzte gleich auch gesagt
vielleicht schauen hier wirklich in die
kommentare wir lesen uns dass durch wir
haben natürlich noch sonst immer darauf
eingehen genau wir haben natürlich noch
so ein paar ziele die wir selber vor uns
erreichen wollen wir beispielsweise hier
diese diese überdachung fertig bauen
oder unten war alles ein bisschen
ausleuchten aber wir wollen natürlich
auch in dem bei den erfolg weiter kommen
deswegen wäre es cool wenn ihr uns der
folge schreiben würdet und also was wir
machen können oder wie das mit den
fischen funktioniert beispielsweise und
dann sind wir auf euch angewiesen
solchen fall hat lasst mir wert von da
an wir sehen uns morgen bei komme wieder